discipline the first function of
leadership
you know i'm happy and smiling when i
see that
in the frequent discussions of
battlefield leadership we are often
prone to overlook the first function of
leadership the development of unit and
individual discipline
the battle is the payoff
said lieutenant colonel ralph ingersoll
and
it is exactly that the payoff on the
leadership which welded individuals into
a smoothly
functioning team discipline applies to
all
captain jack gary company commander of
the 11th infantry
writes discipline is sometimes the
determining factor between winning
and losing
i once listened to a wounded officer
back from fighting in africa who said
forget all the formalities in the field
forget the officer and nco distinctions
in the field
keep all the eight balls they will fight
like hell and i tried to
i looked up this term eight balls and
i i assume it means like uh um like a
rebel type guy
the reason i assume that is because the
next sentence says so that that was the
guy quoting someone from africa he says
i do not believe he had seen very much
action or he would not have made such a
statement
i had a few quote eight balls who did
fight like hell but i have also had a
lot of men who never
caused me trouble who were quiet
confident well disciplined
and these men fought much better so
you know you get that uh in case of war
break glass yeah
thing where look this guy's a little
rough around the edges right yeah it
seemed like when he was like i i also
had guys who were quite calm disciplined
or whatever it just seemed like this
eight ball phenomenon was the opposite
of that yeah yeah they're like the
troublemakers yeah they're a little bit
a little bit wild now look we gotta have
those guys too
we're gonna need those guys and they are
they do have it they can be awesome
for sure because you got to have a
little bit of that
i mean let's face it if you're joining
the military
if you're joining the military to go
into combat arms or you're joining the
military to go into special operations
you're going in that you want to do
something that's you basically want to
do things that are not
legal in the world that's right like
you're going to kill people you're going
to blow things up you're going to plant
bombs that's what you're going through
yeah you can't really do that anywhere
else
that's that's you you know you're a kid
and you're like what do i want to do
when i grow up doctor yeah
lawyer yeah banker yeah
blow things up and kill people that
sounds like a good one
right that's not normal i understand yes
fully
i had a conversation with a guy the
other day and he was like telling me
that
um he was having a conversation with a
guy that was a ceiling he's like you
know there's something that made me
nervous
because when this guy was a young seal
he said you know what
i was asking him hey you know you you
think you're ready to kill people and
you know you're
you're going to deploy and this was kind
of as iraq was going on and this was
like a younger seal that was going to be
heading to iraq and
the young seal was like oh yeah i'm
ready i want to kill people
and he's you know the guy says you know
it just seemed a little bit it seems
like it shouldn't be like that
and i was like it's like that bro
you ask you know a frontline
infantry grunt whatever well i can't i
can't speak for all them
you talk to most a vast majority of
seals
and you say hey if the enemy presents
themselves an opportunity the enemy if
there's an
opportunity for you to kill the enemy
will you be
is happy the right word will you be
will you hesitate in the moment of truth
they'll be like one negative
they'll be stoked so that's the reality
so
there's a little eight ball yeah you
know
let's face it he's down for the cause
yeah now that's
that's the thing is the gr the very
good soldier that you want has that
capability but
has the discipline to keep it under
control the whole uh
the little clip you made of jordan
peterson and i talking about the dane
the
the good man is a dangerous man who has
their their their danger and their
aggression
under control under through discipline
voluntary
under voluntary control that's what
we're looking for that's what we're
looking for yeah
actually that's what we're looking for
next section discipline is based upon
confidence
only a few hours later after he had lost
both legs in combat
lieutenant tichenor who had acted as a
platoon leader in 5th division 12th army
group
made this comment to a military observer
our officers
have to be real leaders discipline in
combat depends
largely upon the men's knowing that the
officer in charge of them
knows his business and is not reluctant
reluctant to take necessary risks
a battalion commander of the sixth
armored division in france makes a
similar combat
comment unless the officer or nco knows
his job completely
the men have no faith in him unless the
men have faith in their leaders
their battle discipline will be poor
so when they're talking about discipline
they're like are you is the team gonna
do what they need to do when they get
when they get the orders to do it
and if they have faith in the leader
they'll do it and if they don't guess
what
which is interesting because you think
well you know it's the military it's the
military and if they get ordered do
something no
that's what they're talking about here
that's what they're talking about
doesn't work like that doesn't work like
that anywhere
just because i bark an order at you and
i have rank over you doesn't mean you're
going to do it especially if it's going
to get you killed
there's a comment here and in these
books they just they the
sort of the authority chimes in the
author or whoever the author is the
the authors chime in and they just write
comment and it says comment a leader who
has not
gained the respect respect and
confidence of his men
during training has two strikes again
when he against him when he enters
combat
the element of doubt in the minds of his
men may be the difference between
success
and failure of a mission gaining respect
and confidence of your men how do you do
that do that by barking at him no
you do that by yelling at him no you do
that by listening you do that by
treating them with respect
here is a definition of discipline says
colonel e l munson signal core
true discipline is voluntary
it is based on knowledge region a sense
of duty
and idealism a good leader develops in
his men
a cheerful and willing obedience
that wants to respond that wants to
carry out his orders
this kind of discipline will in the end
bring combat results as no other kind
possibly can
we could probably stop right here
because everyone thinks when the
military
talks about discipline they're talking
about the
if you can beat your people into
submission
then you're going to be good to go no
that's not the kind of discipline we're
talking about
cheerful willing obedience
that's a totally different thing willing
obedience
people want to carry out the orders
totally different
you don't really think of discipline
associated with
cheerful yeah you the context that
they're using is military discipline is
like hey
do the does the team respond
and execute what they're told to do with
discipline
right so
in the context of that we there's
multiple ways to achieve that
one of them is by beating people right
that you're gonna do this
and you beat them and they're afraid and
they're doing it out of fear
the other way is they're doing it
because they understand because they're
part of it
the result is the result is similar
but what this guy is saying is that
the one that will bring comrade results
like no other kind is the kind where
it's a positive discipline yeah when
they're
saying it's a self-imposed discipline
we're
doing this because we want to yeah not
because someone's barking at us